how can we calculate the cube of any two
digit number without using a calculator
really fast
let's see let us take an example 13
cubed in this number there are two
digits one and three one multiplied by
which number gives us three
correct 3. so on the left side we will
write 1 cubed after that 1 cubed
multiplied by 3
then 1 cubed multiplied by 3 multiplied
by 3
and then we write this so we get 4 parts
the answer of one cubed is one the
answer to this is three for this it's
nine and for this it's 27 after that we
have to multiply these two parts by two
remember that in any case you will have
to multiply the middle two parts by the
number two only 3 times 2 is 6 and 9
times 2 is 18. we have to write just one
digit everywhere so here we will write 7
then 2 carried forward 2 plus 9 plus 18
gives us 29 so we write 9 here and 2
here two plus three plus six is eleven
so you heard we write one and one is
carried forward one plus one gives us
two so here's our answer two one nine
seven using the same concept can you
tell me the value of 14 cubed in the
comment section
we just got acquired by infinity learn
and we wanted to share the happiness
with you
for a limited period we have an
unbelievable offer for you
do check out the links in the
description and the first comment below